well we are about to have liftoff so
their game is gonna start very soon in
terms of dealing with time pressure I
know that Yasuo is very fast what has
your experience been with training
charlie
I think that's one of his one of his
issues is he he really likes to think
which is a good property and here
they're off but he definitely can get in
time pressure sometimes he overthinks
things so he'll have to keep an eye on
that and 1.e4 has been played here we
see the caro-kann defense indeed alright
profit Dania predict a move where we're
gonna see a blunder just for fun just
around I'm gonna predict to move 18 move
18 ladies and gentlemen we'll see if the
Prophet did it once again of course we
will Bishop out to f5 mm-hmm mm-hmm
I was gonna say the reason why it's
important to bring the bishop out first
is because he wants to push east six and
it's always good to activate your bishop
outside of the pawn chain right but well
the thing that we talked about with with
Charlie is that is that against this
move you bring your queen out early to
b3 and what that accomplishes is that
exploits the newly-created weakness of
the b7 square charlie kind of confirming
that here and do you think Hikaru showed
yeah so this line absolutely and
definitely they watched my stream which
happened after he Cara's stream and
advised anymore that's a blunder hunters
upon on b7 which Charlie can simply
capture oh my gosh so now you show
Charlie another idea and yeah again last
time Charlie won the game on mu six and
now he won upon on music diamond can you
coach me two men I believe this is
absurd please help me to now I can't
believe this 97 saves the rook but after
that either Bishop to b5 or Bishop to f4
that is a big blunder by Yasuo here now
Charlie I'm assuming yeah so we'll see
97 because that's really forced and then
let's not celebrate prematurely those of
you or Charlie fans Yassa was very good
at defending and after 97 at which he
finds it's hard to follow the soft
Bishop b5 is not an easy move to find an
either especially F
so Charlie will have to think on his
feet here but this is a big big opening
moment
white after Bishop before I think is
almost winning objectively well why
don't we take a listen to yeah so and
see what he has to say about this move
definitely lose the pawn but in general
doesn't matter I'd rather think of his
moves of what he's attacking I just I'm
moving quick this is not it coach yep
Charlie I mentioned this pawn situation
this time situation well he still seems
very focused and at least he's not you
know shocked or feeling nervous cuz then
he would play worse yeah definitely and
he strike is here what worries me about
Charlie's definitely I mean if he spends
five minutes here figuring stuff out
he's not gonna have enough time for the
middle he doesn't know what to do I
guess I guess he's thinking about
developmental moves he could I guess go
here and look for a double-a somebody
but doesn't really do anything he's just
gonna waste time
he's pricey just develop his his Knights
cuz this is already bad this Knights
hard to get develop he definitely missed
the the scariest thing about this
position which was the Bishop g5 I mean
Charlie is playing very well yeah I mean
Knight f6 here holds on because Bishop
takes Knight on d7 it's a humongous
threat and reason why it's a threat just
to slow down a little bit is because if
the Queen takes the knight the Queen is
no longer protecting the rook on a8 so
the rook is then hanging and if you know
Bishop takes you can't take back with
your king so the only other option would
be to play a move like Bishop e7 but
that's just totally lost so Knight f6 is
a great find by Yasuo so that he can
recapture with a knight right and now
you know the best move is probably
Bishop Allen to f4 in order to go to
but from a practical perspective Bishop
to g5 could be a very dangerous move for
black to deal with because I'm not sure
how to deal with that move exactly
Bishop to g5 pins the knight on f6 and
then threatens Bishop captures night on
d7
so knowing Charlie my guess is he's
gonna play Bishop g5 and yeah so we'll
have to think on his feet there that
puts black in a very very dangerous
opening situation well let's actually
take a look so now what Charlie is doing
so that we can see if that's his plan
he's very focused here yes yes okay I
think yes he does and he takes Sundy
seven that is inaccurate because now the
knight recaptures and he drops his Queen
back that's actually totally fine you
guys plays it safe for it for a second I
saw him dropping his Queen back in the
wrong move order cuz I was listening in
but that makes it could have held the
pin but I'm just gonna go back to normal
move alright so he thinks it was a bad
move and now yeah so actually has a good
position like that yeah I mean he's got
enough compensation for the pawn that's
super trapped just listening in to see
what he's saying here
oh no he seems nervous he is he is and
yeah so playing very quickly here that's
gonna be big we need four is a decent
move like we don't like it because I
don't like it developing so quickly
that's why he's uncomfortable mm-hmm now
yeah so should develop his Bishop on f8
to d6 he's blank perfectly I told you
yeah so is so strong he played
everything well after the blunder
b7 yeah Bishop f4 would have been
crucial there to stop rook b8 and but
it's okay Charlie just needs to develop
which she does he's gotten a lot quieter
all of a sudden but I like that he's
always quiet when he's taking it
seriously but then when he plays well
his personality comes out right and
Bishop d3 here would be an incredibly
strong I would be shocked with full due
respect if he also finds this to prevent
white from castling short oh my gosh
that crazy now it's not intuitive
because he just wants to finish
development which makes sense castle
castle I think from the perspective of
these players I would say the position
is about equal white is up upon black is
excellent development anybody's game and
when you say from the perspective of
these players do you think that their
level or you know even if grandmasters
were playing this black is definitely
better here black if Yasuo handles this
correctly black is significantly better
because he's got a huge initiative the
thing is in a position like this when
you don't have experience it's hard to
position your pieces well yeah so might
be struggling here to figure out exactly
what to do Charlie on the other hand has
a very clear system of development that
we talked about in part you can develop
his knight on b1 he can develop his rook
on f1 it's harder for you so to find a
system of development here but we'll see
how he handles that given the way he's
played I have confidence in him as well
well part of the reason it's hard for
him to figure out development is because
this pieces already have really nice
squares so he's gotten everything
completed now and it'll be tough for him
to figure out how to follow up i quiet
moves like rook e8
you know f6e five that's something that
you know somebody who's been playing in
tournaments for awhile would see but i
think given that he's on his fourth week
of chess that's a very slow plan to go
for and I see just I had a stream on
immunity suffering over a five which
would not be a great move that doesn't
accomplish much another problem for him
is Queen on d8 is tied down to the night
on d7 a move like Queen f6 would have
been excellent except it drops the
knight so he's gotta solve that problem
as well
and by the way he's taking a lot of time
Queen c7 is a reasonable move but
probably it would have been better to
play Knight b6 followed by Queen f6
still very reasonable choice by Yasuo
win ce7 developing the queen putting
pressure on that h2 pond potentially I
think now's another great moment to
listen in on his stream see how he's
thinking about this tricky position and
good beats - he's the quieter than he is
in practice games I think he really
doesn't want to waste any time if I go
here let me think if I go here
he definitely has ideas I'm going here
and hitting my piece then I can just go
here though and attack the Queen
compared to mine look at my pieces
attacking attacking attacking attacking
double attack my piece is about to get
here and win a pawn in a second - do you
think we have enough arrows on board
here look they just winged the pawn what
do you think of this plan Danya well it
was Knight g4 it's a little superficial
though because they just Jackson Cox the
knight back off but I like its ambitious
and I gave this advice to Charlie yeah
so doing the same thing just creating
threats is gonna be huge here Charlie's
got to see that on an h2 and he's got to
prevent that that is a must right and I
do like that he's going for this instead
of the pawn pushes even if it's slung
upon here direct and I'm looking at his
mouse here he's going for his knight and
that is not the right piece to reach to
and he plays 95 it's about to hit at
back h3 is that knife in chief or do you
think yeah throws confidence is a good
thing yeah and here we see h3 by Charlie
both of these place things so well here
Wow and I think it's a great thing
because with this time control the
faster you play the more confidently you
play it projects to your opponent it
reflects itself in the moves that you
play and we just see in the pieces place
piece placement from yeah so we can see
his confidence shining through I believe
that is important psychology is the part
of the game especially
here with so much on the line both of
these players are huge streamers hugely
successful but trust me and I think
you'd agree with me Alexandre they are
shaking right now both of them are
nervous even Yasuo
oh absolutely and to see this kind of
move I'm honestly just very impressed
because it's such a quiet move to see
and 95 did look intuitive because you're
putting your knight in the center you're
blocking the threat so moist critical
not only found a nice strategical move
but he also showed his calculation
skills by not blundering 95 here we see
yeah so deferring dropping his knight
back to f6 and 95 a reasonable move now
it works because he kicked that he saw
that he has to kick the knight out first
and now his knight on e5 is protected
twice it's only attacked twice so
there's no worry if yeah so it grabs
that night if you start seeing moves
like 92 Knight of 3 I'm so impressed
Alexandra I I don't care how this game
ends I am equally impressed with but and
I'm not gonna pretend that I haven't
coached one of them but I'm equally
impressed with the playing level of both
of these but everybody in the chat has
to understand these are players who
virtually had no basically a nodding
acquaintance with the game until three
weeks ago and this is how they are
playing that is just diligence and
grinding on display right here and I am
really impressed just no words no
clothes they're both near five minutes
on the clock
I think this is look at the closest game
I've seen in a while and and Danya we're
on move 16 your prediction was a blunder
on move 18 life it actually happens on
move 18 I'm gonna be scared Alexandra
what will I do with all this power it'll
be crazy but here Charlie has to bring
his other night out in 92 and Knight f3
right and a little bit more planned we'd
be surprised with if he sees because
it's kind of slow right and he has to
understand that he wants to reroute his
knight to f3 and we talked about this in
our lessons the the idea of going 90 to
90 well we also talked about is
developing the bishop on c1 which would
be a terrible idea gotta see that the
rook on b8
is putting pressure on the pawn on b2 so
the bishop on c1 is tied down at the
moments to that pawn on b2
that is a static kind of I wanted to say
a static dynamic but we talk in normal
language here none yeah absolutely yeah
that's just something that is sits there
it's easy to forget about the fact that
that rook is putting pressure on the
point you can forget about that I move
the bishop a Charlie has to move this is
monka s honestly he's got less than five
minutes he has got to trust himself he
can't dip himself down to two minutes oh
no and I see he's hovering the rook he's
about to bring the rook T up a three but
no he he put it back so oh my god he
played ninety-two look at this look at
this play 92.3 patience by Charlie
doesn't lift the rook up yet incredible
both of these players incredible and
we'll see now now the ball in yeah so
escort move 17-under
right and I mean a move like 94 is
interesting for him here if he wants to
just trade off because if he doesn't
move his pieces ideas like a five as you
mentioned earlier they don't really have
a follow up plan
I like h6 because it gives the bishop
space to go back to and you create some
space but it's also a very slow move to
see it is because players have decided
they want to do something they want to
get something done rook to you not bad
just kind of biding his time that real
kind of close to all Charlie three oh my
gosh are we watching grandmasters this
looks like some serious high-level
position on is she from wakens e 2008 I
wouldn't yes exactly
or Ostrovsky I mean Moyes critical which
is leaning it he does look like a strop
skis double or something oh yes he does
incredible and now the clock situation
concerning now for Yasuo as well he is
below four minutes okay well let's take
another look into Moises stream and see
what he's doing
look at that focus Wow
I know he looks so focused I feel like
this is the world championship match or
something it's gonna go down in history
that's a great move 94 they're playing
perfectly both of them 94 threatening
crazy oh my gosh
but I will say that in the game
yesterday with Nate hill and Foose Lee
they also played perfectly the first
half of the game and then they made up
with it with like a crazy amount of
blunder some time pressure uh-huh and
that's what it's coming down to here
Bishop g5 is a bad move it allows a fork
I see I'm looking at Charlie stream he's
about she's hovering over Bishop g5 he's
hovering over it that's not a good move
oh no oh no
Danya the blunder was on move 19 almost
movie I was very close very close has to
give up a piece he's got to go Bishop h4
because that pins the rook and then if
yaso captures the knight he captures the
rook and he's in pretty good shape
chat honestly though that was pretty
close
I feel like danya's a prophet in
training he's not super GM yet but he's
he's certainly getting up there okay
yeah don't be uncomfortable Don he
already predicted this is how you would
feel in fact what if thought if he's too
accurate you guys would be worried so he
saw that situation in the future and
decided to be off a little bit
intentionally yeah and yeah now he's
below three minutes this is not looking
good but we know how fortunes can change
in this tournaments it's just that he's
just taking way way way too long decide
on these decisions at who that's not a
good move he's tilting here he's gonna
be down at peace
now that doesn't mean anything because
if you also recaptures on e5 he's gonna
lose that piece right back without three
first word I've heard from moist
critical he's just saying he's so long
time see yeah so it has to resist the
temptation to capture on e5 really wins
back the piece at the end with
everything real here so two pawns for
the piece for Charlie this is not and
you've blunders right back let's see if
Charlie oh not good mr. g5 man he could
have won that piece back by taking the
bishop and pinning and that's good I
didn't see that well I think they have a
drastic change in their quality of play
as the time gets low which makes sense
it takes a long time to learn how to
deal with time pressure yeah so they're
playing about like an I would say like
an 1800 this game remember what I told
you I've never seen anyone improve this
quickly I wasn't exaggerating it's
insane it's insane incredible and now
the b2 font is saying Charlie
to defend it with a move like Queenie to
oldest sport hold his place
I've knew I should go in here I even saw
this cut off my rook I can't bring my
actions he's got a focus on the present
here is my Clive so even he saw that -
he's feeling a little down on himself
that's rough
I hope he doesn't spend too long feeling
bad about the past coz he can still turn
it around yes he can Queen a 4 would be
a nice trap move here because then if
the rook captures on b2 yes Queen takes
rook mate rugby 1 1 giving up another
exchange of heat now yeah so can can
take on g5 and take on d1 given the way
he's played I feel like he's gonna be
yeah Wow are you kidding me is yeah so
actually a human engine insane feel like
he's a neural net or something he's like
300 rating just because he didn't have
enough data points and with each game he
has like some kind of exponential growth
this is freaking me out I is freaking
out as well but he's not taking the rook
he's taking too long here deciding well
let's let's see if you see oh he's
hovering over oh okay is he yeah wrong
bishop yeah it looks like you were about
to play rook f8 you can't let himself -
okay I spoke too soon not a bad move
though he's still up a piece but
Charlie's got to play fast here he's got
to equalize the time mm-hmm Queenie -
for example all right well we're
swapping to Yasuo his audio now to see
what he has to say see if I'm missing
anything
or more like what his music is saying in
the back you can't take this by the way
because takes so he's just thinking
along it's not even that focus he's
chilling jamming you stretch it and like
it's gym story you're having a ball here
cheese Charlie's got to move it was for
this you know let himself this is slow
don't choke try not to and I kind of
went there and then you can't take
because my queen is threatening but then
if I ever move this if I remove that you
could just take sense so he sees most of
the tactics he's losing a lot of time
all you do the up I'm in and a half now
I might just win you just missing the
point
yeah and that's almost a good idea cuz
now Charlie's even more indecisive than
usual g3 okay lucky you're over this up
pickle sack thing to the stuff that
really good getting down on himself too
much six easily another amazing mode oh
my gosh what would you put yeah so it's
real strength ice 14 1500 is n16 on this
game I mean with some exceptions 14 1500
maybe 16 ahead of moves if he plans on
something how I react to it I could also
if he goes here I go here but then he
could just start moving the square
that's bad I need to get I think I want
to move this inside the center more
potentially to don't seem too bad here
here here takes takes then I'm getting
more the center and getting her into the
pawns and I'm opening with my diagonals
for my fish up oh he speaks faster than
most GM's I know it's unbelievable below
30 seconds he's gonna lose on time he's
just just doesn't see his clock oh man
but it's not just his clock the position
is so hard he's about to get attacked he
has you know pieces hanging everywhere
so he made a move just to make a move
here right but he's got to do that he's
got to see the clock above all else yeah
that's very fair okay let's go back to
Moyes critical
well no it's plus five right I get that
I get a net right
is he noticing this rule fine he is now
h4 quickly that's a good movement now h6
and Bishop takes g3 yeah if yeah so sees
that I mean it's pretty intuitive though
cuz you're kicking the night out
oh oh she takes c3 is not at all if he
sees it I your 14 1500 and he's
definitely the top 4 in terms of
favorites for for the event or maybe the
top 5 subside oh definitely
if he sees Bishop takes g3 I'll be
stunned Oh help moment of truth come in
and reel to go doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo
that's let's see exactly music you know
preparing for that that move chat is he
gonna play it is he in play Bishop takes
g3 g4 attacking the Queen he's got a
great mouth - that's a good move - seven
seconds move Sharlee oh gosh he's not
seeing as far three seconds Oh dirty
flag this will be the first dirty flag
in the tournament you know to witness it
two seconds one second no flag oh god I
can't believe I just did that
oh yeah I was at a time a good effort oh
man that was rough but honestly
incredibly it's not even that moist
critical played poorly no I'd say you
played I hate time out
you played excellently but the
middlegame strength by yaso is
unbelievable I mean he put his pieces on
great squares he saw f6
you didn't make any clear mistakes
really I mean other than six yes so he
did see this this was the blunder of the
game I would say yeah definitely giving
up that piece after that everything went
downhill yeah well
that was that was a very exciting game
so that means that Yasuo is going to
move on to the champions division and
moist critical is going to be in the
consolation which is actually not too
bad because he might be of a heavy
favorite there yeah I believe he is so
it might feel bad to lose this game in a
moment but he does have great chance in
the consolation bracket and I like
Charlie but against hot someone like
Hyde she would have had zero chances so
yeah so however is I wouldn't say he's a
favorite but he's someone who's
announced himself and burst onto the
scene and he is no one to be messed with
as he's shown now time and time again
yeah and when I originally interviewed
Yasuo in his first game in pogchamp he
told people his ambition is to win it
all and that he wants to give the fans
something to believe in and after these
games I'm a fan and I believe in yeah so
I'm so impressed me too
and just the way he was thinking he was
reasoning very very quickly and he was
seeing all sorts of tactics just
incredible credit right well let's take
a quick look at the game from the start
here so it we saw a Carol con with c6
and we know that Hikaru prepped yeah so
you prepped Charlie with the white side
of the pieces and he ended up actually
getting a very nice opening because
Nestle probably mixed up his lines when
he played east six and ended up giving a
free pawn on b7 here alright and after
ninety seven Bishop e5 Knight f6 there
was the critical moment where Charlie
kind of released attention too soon you
shouldn't have taken that night because
that basically relinquished the
initiative gave black excellent
development a move like Bishop f4 Bishop
g5 was to be preferred and I'll just
slow down for saying so the reason why
Bishop f4 was so good but also hard to
see is because as soon as yeah so was
able to kick out Charlie's Queen from
the attack then despite being down upon
he had really good piece activity and
being up in development is often worth
as much as a pawn in the opening so if
he would have seen that it would have
helped a lot or at least if he would
have kept the tension with a move like
Bishop g5 but he probably wasn't sure
what to do so he just went for the trade
there
right and that wasn't a terrible idea he
got a decent position and really
everything they put both late flawlessly
up until move nineteen Bishop g5
blundering that for quickly to catch up
with you there alright so Bishop g5
continue Bishop g5 f6 and now the last
maybe chance was to bring the bishop
back to H for keeping the rook on g8
pins the problem being still F takes e5
gives two pieces for a rook after
charlie dropped his bishop back to d2
well then unfortunately for him yeah so
just didn't give him any more chances
like nah it was just perfect play after
their one mistake and he was out well on
that note chat we are gonna take a quick
break we'll do the usual player
interviews afterwards we're gonna take a
look in on slicker in the meantime so we
know that's gonna be a ton of fun
welcome back everyone we are joined by
mo also known as yes fo that is his
twitch handle yes well first of all
congratulations you are playing
incredibly you impressed both Danya and
I and um yeah just mmm we tip our hat to
you oh thank you I appreciate that you
know I just I try to do my best you know
I had a lot of teachers teach me a few
things recently both you know like I
said earlier you
hikaru Gotham chess may be Danya in the
future I don't know you know we got some
some pot to do but I'm just trying to
prove as much as I can and play my best
chest
absolutely well why don't we start by
reviewing the game a little bit do you
see the board and the zoom call yes I do
can we flip it so I see black cuz yeah
sure let's go for it um so when you
played east six were you making the
opening moves quickly and missing b7 or
did you think that you should give away
b7 okay so I definitely missed it I'm
not gonna lie and say I didn't miss it
but the thing is I remember yesterday
talking to Kaoru and I even gave him the
situation he put me in a situation where
my his pawn was hanging and I took the
pawn and then he showed me that it
actually doesn't really matter because
once I get my Bishop out and I start
developing my moves I feel like I'm so
far ahead of him in that scenario in
terms of development that the one pawn I
should be able to win back later is how
I felt
Danya you want to add anything there
yeah well that was we were impressively
that you handled the aftermath
that especially just the way that you
placed your pieces Queen c7 Knight f6
and we kind of sense your confidence
when we were watching your stream so at
what point did you kind of detect that
things were going your way and how did
you go about deciding where to place
your pieces and sort of the middle game
so I felt like I was a little on the
back foot once he took my pawn and I
blundered that and even when I could
have taken the e7 pawn - I think I just
wanted to focus on attacking his King
side and setting up my bishop and the
Queen right behind it and having a
really nice line I felt like I was
pretty ahead in terms of development
some use hard to find certain moves
because like it feels related to get
many games like this when I play many
games in general and then - I've played
many games where I'm so far ahead in
development that I've like find moves
either win pawns or like just kind of I
guess block his pieces from moving so I
was struggling a little bit to find
moves like I was playing I almost
honestly one of the slowest games I've
ever played I was like a little lost in
terms the slowest game you've ever
played and you still had two minutes
left over at the end yeah I just I don't
know I just I got the moves in general
like I feel like I didn't really have
too many bad news I guess like that's
how it felt to me because his pieces
weren't really threatening too hard so I
felt like no matter what I could play
what I played no matter what it was like
always half decent so my goal was just
to develop my pieces and then I was
trying to get my rooks developed it was
kind of hard because the middle was
taken so I was thinking of ideas of
pushing my pawn and taking taking but I
wanted to just make sure I didn't lose
the dark bishop unless I was winning
something because I didn't want to lose
that attacking piece towards the Kings
side and since you've been picking you
know chess up like a sponge I just want
to point out one idea to you so if you
see the current board um a move that you
missed before tasseling but you you
could have also played if he took your
pawn on a7 was a way to stop Charlie
from castling if you place your Bishop
on d3 he can't castle he can't go
through check and then his King is gonna
be stuck in the center of the board and
you can July go for moves like 'if I've
opening it up yeah I think I actually
saw that move just putting my piece
there I just didn't really see what I
gained I forgot honestly that when he
like moves the piece in check then I can
win a rook or whatever it is but I got
scared you I can't he can't castle
through checks right can't move his king
out he's his king vulnerable in the
center way even if he moves his King to
G
gg1 it doesn't matter because like your
legal counsel some travel piece okay
yeah exactly
I don't know that yeah but I get scared
when I keep my pieces too far in the
back line without too much defense
that's why I didn't move my piece they
know it's super reasonable and that's
why we just wanted to show it to you now
so you know for future games cuz we we
didn't expect this move to be one that
comes to mind yeah I appreciate that
what yeah we were impressed with the
rook lift as well moved 25 getting the
rook involved in the attack we saw that
you were generating these attacking
ideas and you put them in practice very
nicely I'm catching up there to the
position where you talked about with the
rook lift okay there we go Daniel it's
on the board mm-hmm yeah so this is this
is a part I guess where it felt like the
middle ground was toward to take because
both of our pawns were kind of just
covering the square so I couldn't get
active that's why I end up pushing the F
pawn I don't really like pushing the
pawns on my Kings side or my King's pawn
cuz like obviously it's like defending
pieces and I want to make sure my Kings
always safe but one didn't have his
light-square bishop and then I also just
have my pawns lined up so you can't do
any funny tricks with the Queen so I
decided to just push it break the middle
a little more and then get my get an
avenue for my rook to get into the game
at this point I wasn't sort of - do I
think when he pushed his pawn to defend
the the the knight I knew that pushing
my rook to h6 didn't really generate any
attacking moves that's why I ended up
just pushing the pawn to give my even my
King more space I guess and then I was
just looking at ways I didn't really
like my problems I don't know how to
attack these pawns on his side like what
would you guys recommend for this
situation where like how do i generate
more of an advantage like is it the way
I played or am I is there any type of
ideas where I can find a mate because I
you know well we actually have a move
after Knight of three so h6 was great
you are moving the knight out of here I
think when you're up material like this
and the white King is so exposed and you
know so naked here you can try to look
for potential sacrifices so one move
that would have been brilliant is
actually if you would have given up your
Bishop for two pawns here because if
you're able to break through the King's
defenses first of all if he takes with
the pawn you're coming in with a queen
and you have checkmate next move true
actually yeah so you can always try to
keep an eye out on sacrifices when your
opponent's King doesn't have that many
pieces nearby so we just have a knight
or when the pawns have moved forward a
lot and there's a ton of space mm-hmm
but your mubarik g4 was from a practical
sense very good because yes early was
sold
on time it's hard to detect that
long-range attack on the Queen yeah
well overall like we said you played
incredibly well I I do have another
question did you see that the bishop was
attacking the rook or you're just too
focused on going in for the kill I saw
it I just so what I saw is that he had a
double attack I think I did I hang my
piece for a second or no I didn't so
when he moved his Knight
I realized that my piece was the under
double attack and either I need to
retreat my P or defend it but I realized
I'm up on material so worst case
scenario I can trade so I decided to
move it there because I know he can't
take with Queen so he'd have to move his
Queen and once he does that I have to
move my bishop but then my rook is in a
better spot than it was before attacking
like house like in a whole entire row I
don't I just felt good to me there
excuse me
well that's I mean what's impressive to
me is your thinking process and just the
work that you put into this game so
absolute kudos hats off to I know that I
coached Charlie I'm gonna be out and say
that but yeah so I was just so impressed
with your play throughout the game so
very well done and you got rewarded for
your grind so I'm very happy to see that
thank you so much I appreciate that
yeah and we were telling you this before
we were alive but Danya said that your
rating is closer to fourteen fifteen
hundred when you came in for the first
interview you were telling people you're
in here to win it all is that still your
ambition so it is I'm a little scared
now because my friend voyboy actually I
think he's group a he's winning group a
and since I lost to hutch I think even
if X you see somehow miracle God comes
down and puts a new brain next you see
and helps him get the dub and like be
touched I still won't I'll slot the play
boy boy so I think I'm kind of scared
now cuz boy was like the favorite to win
the tournament but i yeah i'll still try
my hardest obviously i'll try to prep
figure out some type of opening to put
make a boy boy uncomfortable but what
was really solid players so i guess i'll
see how that works that's gonna be a
tough game well that's a very practical
and objective way to look at it thank
you so much mo for for being here for
the interview and for your just
incredible performance congratulations
once again thank you so much thank you
guys take care